et d'évoquer jeu nous entrons dans une
zone de turbulences mais qu'est ce que
vous faites là et vous entendez ce que
je dis allez vous asseoir attachez-vous
cette fille c'est qui m'est arrivé une
histoire terrible son mari et son fils
sont morts accident de voiture tu crois
que c'est elle qui conduisait sa soirée
chez toi depuis trois jours oui je sais
elle m'a laissé un message
ouf de longs mois passés à prouver après
ok mon fils est attendu ici
non non je suis très fatigué d'ashoka
avec l âge auraient ils vont pousser du
latin histoire est toujours pas entrer
willy ronis et adeline m'écoutais je
suis un peu inquiète elle son téléphone
marche plus comment tu t'appelles qu'ils
les chinois ils pillent téléphone maison
tu habites ou la maison les hommes et 65
pole hier au point que la police est
dingue des s'étonnait fausse adresse
c'est que la pâte papier oui bon duo de
tête une copine de moi finalement ce top
noir
alem maigre comme un canard en hiver fut
changée en charge
le ramener en chine c'est pas vrai
non
dans le fond c'était un cadeau du ciel
enfants question
guinéo le petit il ya la mise il est
tout seul là j'ai fermé la porte à clé
je sais que c'est pas facile tu vas
retrouver la maman tu te faut prouver